si vous voulez bien regagner vos places
la séance est reprise
voici le résultat du scrutin pour
l'élection du président du Sénat nombre
de votants 348
bulletin blanc 22 bulletin nul 6
suffrages exprimé 320 majoritaire
absolue 161
ont obtenu ce Gérard Larcher
218 voix
ce n'est pas un vote pas un vote par
acclamation donc je vais vous donner
quand même les scores des autres
candidats ce Patrick canner a obtenu 64
voix
[Applaudissements]
et monsieur Guillaume Gontard 18 voies
donc Monsieur Gérard Larcher a obtenu la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
au premier tour de scrutin je le
proclame élu président du Sénat et
conformément à l'article premier du
règlement je l'invite à prendre place au
fauteuil de la présidence que je lui
souhaite bien volontiers et je remercie
le secrétaire d'âge pour leur
participation aux opérations de vote le
président
Monsieur le Doyen monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues secrétaire du bureau
chers collègue président de groupe mes
chers collègues
merci tout d'abord Monsieur le Doyen
cher Jean-Marie van derenberg pour vos
propos
et la réflexion que nous avions fait
partager sur la démocratie sur le
Parlement
sur la dimension sociétale et sociale de
notre action et pour la métaphore
maritime qui indiquait le bon port
je souhaite
remercier les secrétaires du bureau
d'âge fonction éphémère que j'ai connu
c'était il y a quelques années
c'est un moment un peu particulier
je voudrais souhaiter la bienvenue à nos
nouveaux collègues
ils deviennent les héritiers et les
porteurs du bicaméricisme
du Conseil des Anciens de 1795 au Sénat
d'aujourd'hui
près de 230 années où notre pays n'a
connu que trois périodes sont deux
assemblées parlementaires
la Convention
avant octobre
1795 mais il y a eu la terreur et la
nécessité du Conseil des Anciens
la deuxième République en 1848 mais qui
après des débuts remplis d'espérance et
de liberté
c'est terminé par un coup d'État le 2
décembre
1852 et une période particulièrement
noire l'État français ou le Parlement et
la République avait disparu
mes chers collègues le bicamérisme est
indispensable à notre démocratie
parlementaire
je veux avoir une pensée de gratitude
pour celles et ceux qui ne siègent plus
parmi nous aujourd'hui ils ont apporté
au Sénat et aux pays et vous avez eu
Monsieur le Doyen une pensée
particulière pour eux
permettez-moi de remercier très
sincèrement celles et ceux qui m'ont
témoigner leur confiance je m'engage à
présider notre assemblée avec la
légitimité que me donne la majorité mais
aussi dans le respect de vos diverses
sensibilités
je vous propose de n'avoir pour boussole
que l'intérêt de notre pays et de
poursuivre la construction du Sénat de
demain je voudrais saluer sincèrement
Patrick canaire Cécile que Kerman et
Guillaume Gontard les présidents de
groupe qui ont été candidats ils ont
témoigné de la pluralité de notre
assemblée je veux leur dire que je serai
comme hier très attentif au respect des
groupes minoritaires et d'opposition
comme d'ailleurs attentif à chaque
groupe politique et à chaque sénateur ou
qu'il siège
oui il existe une manière particulière
au Sénat d'exercer la fonction
parlementaire
être sénatrice être sénateur c'est faire
vivre la démocratie être au service de
la République et des citoyens
quand 62% des Français jugent que le
Sénat joue un rôle important dans la vie
politique française
on mesure le chemin parcouru depuis une
année
nous incarnons plus que jamais ce pôle
de stabilité ce point d'équilibre que
vous m'avez souvent entendu évoqué oui
je pense que le Sénat est plus que
jamais au cœur de notre vie démocratique
être sénatrice être sénateur c'est être
autonome libre et indépendant
c'est aussi se respecter les uns les
autres ces données à nos compatriotes le
visage d'une assemblée où on débarque où
on propose ou parfois on s'oppose mais
jamais dans le mépris la victime ou la
violence
mes chers collègues
il y a me semble-t-il une façon
sénatoriale de faire de la politique
avec sérieux calme détermination
c'est la bonne méthode pour recoudre un
pays fracturé sans craindre de dire la
vérité même si elle dérange on ne
reculant jamais devant l'obstacle
fort de ses principes il nous faut
imaginer construire ensemble le Sénat de
main pour mieux répondre aux attentes de
nos concitoyens et des territoires pour
retrouver la confiance
notre pays qui souffre doute au fond
qu'il a plus confiance a besoin d'une
assemblée attentive j'ose le dire une
assemblée presque affective vis-à-vis de
nos compatriotes
ces dernières années
j'ai sillonné le pays
j'ai rencontré de nombreux élus locaux
et nombre d'acteurs économiques et
sociaux
vous le sentez bien vous traversons une
crise profonde
aggravation des fractures territoriales
monter de l'abstention des votes
contestataires
dégradation de services publics et de la
présence médicale
envolée de la dette publique des
déficits monter des violences et des
émus urbaines
inquiétudes au quotidien face à
l'inflation
une jeunesse inquiète elle aussi
notamment face aux défis climatiques
nous l'avons tous ressenti pendant la
campagne électorale pour ceux qui
étaient candidats que nous venons de
vivre il nous faudra rompre avec cette
spirale du déclin et le Sénat devra y
prendre toute sa part
chers collègues
c'est le sens du projet pour les trois
années à venir que j'ai fait parvenir
chacune et à chacun d'entre vous le
Sénat de la République aujourd'hui et
demain d'abord notre mission
constitutionnelle
le président de la République a par deux
fois en 2017 et en 2022 annoncé son
attention procéder à une réforme des
institutions
j'ai souhaité à chaque fois que le Sénat
soit en anticipation notre groupe de
travail transpartisan se réunit depuis
novembre 2022
et il fera des propositions d'ici la fin
de cette année
nous sommes prêt à envisager toute
réforme qui serait
utile à l'amélioration du fonctionnement
de notre démocratie si elle permet de
recoudre le pays si elle permet au
peuple de retrouver la confiance en ces
parlementaires chez gouvernants sa
justice mais je le dis je le redis notre
constitution de se modifie pas en
fonction des pulsions du moment
[Applaudissements]
la loi
vous êtes de législateur
elle est le cœur de notre mission
ces trois dernières années au travers de
notre mission de législateur nous avons
défendu ensemble dans la diversité de
nos groupes politiques les prérogatives
du Parlement face à toutes les
tentatives de contournement nous avons
lutté contre le recours excessif aux
ordonnances qui déposaient le Parlement
du débat et du droit d'amendement
la loi vous retrouver sa force et son
efficacité doit obéir à quelques
principes
simplicité
lisibilité
efficacité
subsidiarité il nous faut donc moins
légiférer pour mieux légiférer et cela
nous concerne tous exécutif comme nous
tous dans chacune de nos assemblées pour
atteindre cet objectif qui me paraît
essentiel
trop de lois ne sont jamais
appliquées ou inefficace
devant les évaluer avant et après vote
l'annonce d'un projet de loi est trop
souvent devenu un outil de communication
pour les réseaux sociaux et les médias
méfions-nous des lois de pulsion qui
produisent cette inflation législative
qu'il nous faut combattre
notre mission de contrôle
elle est essentielle au contre-pouvoirs
que nous incarnons nous avons été
fidèles à l'esprit des lois oui le
pouvoir doit arrêter le pouvoir c'est ce
qui écrivait Montesquieu et la société à
droite demandait compte à tout agent
public de son administration c'est
l'article 15 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen c'est ce
que nous avons fait au cours de ces
trois années c'est ce que nous ferons
enfin nous portons la voie des
territoires
convaincu que la gouvernance verticale
la suradeministration
l'hyperconcentration du pouvoir sont en
partie à l'origine des mots dont souffre
notre pays nous devons remettre les mers
au cœur de la décision gérer en
proximité
imposer un nouveau souffle de
décentralisation mais à décentralisation
forte il faut un état territorial fort
nos collectivités ont besoin de plus de
liberté c'est vrai pour les communes
c'est vrai pour les départements c'est
vrai pour les régions
il nous faudra trouver un juste
équilibre entre différenciation et
unités de la République
le 6 juillet dernier
15 propositions pour rendre aux élus le
pouvoir d'agir ont été rendus publics et
adressés au président de la République
et à la première ministre
simplification
autonomie fiscale et financière statut
de l'élu relation entre les services de
l'état des mers logements et bien
d'autres points encore c'est donc une
main tendue loyalement et concrètement
par le Sénat à l'exécutif je souhaite
que l'exécutif saisissent cette main
tendue
[Applaudissements]
en ces temps
où l'équilibre institutionnel a été
profondément modifiée du fait de
l'absence de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale ou le fait majoritaire n'est
plus le Sénat un rôle essentiel dans le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
il est parvenu à être le point
d'équilibre d'une démocratie à la peine
une assemblée qui assume ses différences
qui résistent à la désinformation
parfois alarmante à la justice
expéditive des réseaux sociaux
Michel devrait l'anticiper déjà devant
le Conseil d'État et je le cite c'était
en août 1958
il est facile de comprendre pourquoi il
faut à la France une puissante deuxième
chambre
notre régime électoral peut nous
empêcher de connaître les majorités
cohérentes qui assurent sans règles
détaillées la bonne marche du régime
parlementaire
c'est donc aujourd'hui pour nous une
responsabilité supplémentaire et pour la
première fois d'ailleurs
réellement depuis 1958
la démocratie représentative mes chers
collègues et fragile il faut en prendre
soin attention à l'image que nous
projetons dans l'opinion faisons la
vivre en étant ouvert
disponible à l'écoute soyons attentifs
au pouls de la société
à l'extérieur du pays né à doute sur le
rôle et le rang de la France dans le
monde
j'ai dans mes déplacements à l'étranger
rencontrer nos compatriotes établis hors
de France nous devons y être
particulièrement attentif à ses
compatriotes et être solidaire je pense
aujourd'hui
à ce que nous vivons à ce qu'ils vivent
en Afrique
soyons attentifs aux puissances
nouvelles qui émergent sur le continent
africain et en Indo-Pacifique et qui
bouleverse déséquilibres qui semblaient
durablement être installés
nous devons faire face à de nouveaux
défis crise migratoire crise climatique
sur lesquelles nous devons être
particulièrement
mobilisé sache que chant ou la
démocratie mais surtout la diplomatie
parlementaire peut être utile je veux
mes chers collègues avoir une pensée
toute particulière et solidaire en cette
journée
du 2 octobre pour l'Arménie et les
Arméniens qui ont le sentiment qu'ils
sont à nouveau bien seuls et qu'il sache
que nous sommes à leur côté
ensemble nous allons vivre trois années
d'engagement au service des Français ou
services de la République je crois
profondément que le Sénat aura une
responsabilité particulière pour
mobiliser les forces vives de notre pays
et faire vivre la démocratie nous
devrons rester l'assemblée du débat
apaisé une assemblée responsable face
aux défis qui se présente
intransigeantes à chaque fois que les
intérêts de la France l'exigeront c'est
comme cela que nous réussirons
rassembler les Français pour retrouver
un sentiment commun d'appartenance à la
nation oui nous devons retrouver
confiance et espérance alors ce que je
vous propose c'est de participer
ensemble à cette ambition collective
nous avons une responsabilité
particulière
pour les trois années qui viennent une
responsabilité que nous devrons assumer
dans la diversité de ce que nous sommes
de ce que nous représentons que le
soyons en métropole dont nous outre-mer
quelque part vous incarnons une France
qui connaît cher doyen sont caps qui
doit tenir son cap le cap c'est
l'intérêt de la France pour que vive le
Sénat vive la république et vive la
France
[Applaudissements]
merci encore
mes chers collègues je vous propose de
confirmer par consensus est aussi un
élément de notre culture le calendrier
de la suite du renouvellement des
instances du Sénat tel qu'Il vous a été
communiqué y a-t-il des oppositions
je n'en vois pas il en est ainsi décidé
j'attire votre attention sur
l'importance de votre présence
et de votre ponctualité
pour la réalisation de la photographie
officielle du Sénat dans l'hémicycle le
jeudi 5 octobre
si vous n'êtes pas là il y a pas de
réinjection de photos
et pendant 3 ans on ne voit pas vos
visages partout ce serait malheureux
donc je souhaite vraiment que vous soyez
là je rappelle le 5 octobre à 14h30
l'ordre du jour des prochaines semaines
sera fixée par la Conférence des
présidents qui se réunira jeudi prochain
à 18h
pas de motion particulière je vous
remercie la séance est levée